good morning everyone welcome to this
meeting of the play planning committee I
will now ask the governance officer to
read out the domestic Arrangements in
the fire regulations Claire thank you
thank you chair
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations While
others are speaking if you're attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off and
that your laptop is also switched to
silent we'll be using the e-voting for
this meeting on the modern gov app so
please good members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium if you are in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs to the nearest exit because
the stairs not the lifts and do not
re-enter the building until it's hold it
is safe to do so
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair thank you Claire
some quick introductions today we have
attending the area planning manager Mark
Russell
legal advisor Ian Duprey the case
officer today is Alex Scott and you've
already met Claire Philpot
do we have any apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apology
Barrett and councilor Sue Ayers is
substituting
Declarations of Interest are there any
to declare
nope
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 21st
the first October it's a long day
September
there's a statement from the chief
planning officer that needs to be added
to the minutes
okay so the statement reads as follows
this is regarding application number
dc2106519
further to the draft minutes I would
like to report an update following the
authorities delegated to me under the
resolution
at the meeting I advise the proposal and
secondary of the motion that a reason
for refusal based upon the impact the
development upon TPO preserved trees
would be appropriate and this formed the
basis for the delegation I was mistaken
in that advice and apologized for
incorrectly advising councilors and
committee on that point in actuality the
tree is affected by the development are
not subject
of tree preservation order
I've taken a purposive approach to
committee's intention here and proceeded
to issue the refusal decision noticed in
exercise of the delegation without
reference to impact the development upon
preserved trees I have instead amended
the reasons to reflect the impact upon
trees generally rather than upon
preserved trees the refusal reason is as
issued is as follows
paragraph 131 of the mppf 2021 together
with development plan policies cs15 and
cn01 require inter-alia that existing
trees are retrained retained within
development proposals wherever possible
and that local features are retained
creating interesting and attractive
spaces in the interests of good design
the site for this application benefits
from significant tree presence that
enhances the landscape character Visual
and local amenities at the park and the
townscape hereabouts
proposed development would result in
material tree loss across the site
including mature utree that has a
historical association with Bellevue the
cumulative loss of these landscape
townscape features would be harmful to
the overall character and amenity value
of the site contrary to the principles
of good design and to the aims of the
above mentioned policies
thank you
thank you Claire
Mr chairman can I just go up after a
clarification on that we're referring to
the barrel View application because I
haven't got the minutes with me
unfortunately yeah
it's referring to to the one we had on
the 21st of it was just a single
application included the Bellevue house
that's correct and um is this in respect
of the tree that was going to be fouled
which we didn't want it
um we weren't keen on losing that tree
is this the area that you're referring
to
yeah it is because I remember when we
chatted with the chief planning officer
he hadn't got all the right words for
that and this has neither the right word
that third reason
delegated to the chief planning officer
to put the final word in together and
this is that final wording so when we
vote today on the minutes you're voting
on the minutes reflect what happened
during the meeting and this is what's
come from the chief planning after thank
you will we get a copy of that
or will that be in the minutes yes it's
in the decision notice but I can also
send you a copy of
copy yeah yeah I think that would be
very helpful the minutes were issued
yesterday in the table papers so if
you'd like a paper copy now we've got a
few if you would like yes please
thank you thank you for that
clarification thank you
thank you Council
could I ask chair that uh our legal
representative is happy with this and
that everything is above board and um
we'll have no problems
yes chairman I I am indeed it's a
refusal so the remedy usual remedies and
appeals to the Secretary of State
however we must always remember that
it's not a known for a refusable subject
to a judicial review but I think the
chief planning officer has done done his
best and made a judgment that is I
understand and agree with that it was
proper for him to do that without taking
the whole item back for reconsideration
I think he has he
followed the Committees the instruction
of the majority of the committee to
refuse and he's crafted the best reason
for refusal that corresponds with the
resolution give him the facts the full
facts we now know
sorry Chad I think it was more a case of
the reason that the officer gave was
obviously not what was voted on so I
just wanted to make sure legally that we
were okay that the chief land officer
could do that without it coming back to
be voted on
is that in addition to the minutes that
we've got or is it replacing one of them
at this condition
of both the other two points
okay good
just technically I think it would be in
replacement of the final line delegate
to delegate to the CPO to finalize the
involvement and reason for refusal and
to prepare reason for refusal related to
the loss of TPO preserved trees the
paragraph the officer read out would be
replacing that line in fact the minutes
of the meeting yeah remain the same
because reflect what others agreed at
the
will be now reported in the minutes for
today's meeting and perform part of the
decision notice for that application but
the minutes you're voting on today
will stay the same unless there's
anything else right there but in effect
it modifies the decision notice thank
you yeah so just the decision notice
that's correct sorry
we are not TPO trees that is the point
isn't it that that's the only yeah
okay
the rest of the minutes are there any
points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes
no in that case
could I have a proposal to accept the
minutes councilor beer
Council Osborne seconds
thank you
last United vote thank you
thank you chair
no progress in your app
you did stay in counselors as you
weren't here before
but yeah
councilor Osborne would you like me to
take your vote verbally
it's okay
just no problem thank you thank you
members chair that's nine votes for and
two extensions thank you
moving on
receive notification of petitions
many site inspections to consider
right we will move on to the planning
applications
um
DC
2201754 land east of Hadley Road Elm
said Suffolk which first of all asked
Council Jameson if you'll be staying on
the committee or speaking as a ward
member
uh understand the committee
thank you
I know invite the case officer Aaron
Scott to introduce the application to
the committee over to Alex
thank you chairman
so this is uh item 6A in the in the
papers application reference DC forward
slash 22 forward slash zero one seven
five four
land east of Hadley Road Elm set
uh the application before you is an
application for full planning permission
the erection of 44 dwellings including
35 percent affordable homes
landscaping and public open space
in the play area
and there is also a section 106 which is
running in tandem with the application
uh
and to secure the proposed affordable
homes uh landscape being management the
public open space and the
the play area as well as off-site
Skylark mitigation
a financial contribution towards
Secondary School transportation costs as
requested by the the County Council
and contribution towards highways
improvements as uh requested by the
local Highway Authority at Suffolk
County Council
so this first slide shows the um the
wider a wider aerial view of the
Site Area and the site is etched in red
here at Elm Elm set
and we have the neighboring Village of
Oldham here
with the the street leading off to the a
1071 and Hadley in this direction
and what field is off in this direction
and then uh birstall Spartan and
that direction
this is a closer aerial view of the site
so the site itself is edged in orange
and purple hatched
and we have
Hadley Road here
running adjacent to the uh to the west
of the site
we have garage uh
Road here
and adjacent dwellings frontal to that
existing estate in a state of first
Sawyers in this location
and other adjacent Estates at windings
Road and downwinds
over here to the uh to the north
Northeast
this is a constraints map uh
planning constraints
the site is outside the Bilter period
boundary of the village that is
indicated by this uh this Brown Line
however the site is allocated for
Housing Development policy em
st3 the development plan of the of the
neighborhood plan
there are two public right-of-ways uh
affecting the site uh the northernmost
actually runs within the site adjacent
to the northern boundary
and the southernmost is acts like the
site uh
protect side of existing uh hedge and
tree planting to the to the field
boundary
the field itself is grade 3 agricultural
land
and the colored buildings you can see
there are our listed buildings grade two
listed buildings uh further in the
towards the center of the village and um
not considered to be greatly affected by
the development
development this is just an additional
slide
um
put in showing the approximate location
of TPO trees as referenced in the report
so this indicates one to the
Hadley Hadley Road boundary onto the
onto the south field boundary and to to
the existing
East field boundary
this is the site location plan submitted
with the application and the site
extends to approximately 2.5 hectares
this is the latest current uh site
layout
[Music]
provided by the applicant
so in total there are 29 Market houses
proposed
uh 12 of which would be two bedroom
with uh including four bungalows
and there would be nine three bedroom
six four bedroom
two five bedroom Market houses in total
the scheme includes four 15 affordable
homes as is required by the policy
policy em st3 of the neighborhood plan
four of which would be shared ownership
and 11 of which would be for affordable
rent as advised by your strategic
housing officers
and in total there would be nine
two-bedroom including one Bungalow and
six three bedroom affordable houses
proposed
and this is a close-up of the uh the
northern part of the site and the uh the
Ford affordable homes are indicated with
the the colored dots the blue indicates
uh shared ownership
and the red indicates for affordable
rent
uh this is the uh
play area proposed as part of the
development um
a leap so a locally equipped area for
play so the um
in terms of the provision it's sort of
The Middle
in terms of scale below that we have
lap which is um
lesser provision
and leap above that so
sort of middling
um
area for play there
there was some initial concern raised by
your Environmental Protection officers
in terms of the distance to to
boundaries particularly to the rear
boundaries and dwellings at garage Road
here to the north that has subsequently
been amended by the applicant and we now
have sufficient distance of of 20 meters
away from those boundaries to the
satisfaction of your environment
there was still some concern raised with
regards the impact on future occupants
but um
it's your officer's consideration that
that is a
sort of a buyer beware uh situation and
uh those uh moving in uh to the
dwellings would be aware that there
would be a player in close proximity
and indeed
um that seen as somewhat as a benefit
having a um a player in close proximity
to a dwelling so um
what's going on there and children
um
and we also have the flood risk
attenuation Basin in this
in this location this has been um
assessed and addressed by the lead local
flood Authority at Suffolk County
Council
and we also have the uh
existing route of the public
right-of-way which is proposed to be
improved as part of the application as
required by policy em st3
and then uh to the South uh we have
the southern um dwellings and some more
affordables to the uh to the southern
boundary
and here is the uh the Hadley Road uh
Street Scene
uh provided in its uh totality on the
top row
and uh just some closer views of that
before you split into two
on the bottom rows so that's what you'd
see as you pass the site from Hadley
Road
this is the Landscaping
plan which has been provided with uh
with the application
and so we have enhancements to existing
perimeter hedgerows with Native species
additional native species planting
throughout the site
and drought and flood resilient species
are proposed to all swales and
attenuation basins so that
will be planting in those
um
whether it would be dry or um or wet
and onto the elevations of all the
dwellings proposed so in total we have
uh 16 different design variations
[Music]
elevations and floor plans
come back to these if there are any uh
particular questions from members
so these are the market dwellings first
and onto the affordable dwellings
and onto some photographs so this is the
existing um
Hadley Road Site Frontage and uh
existing Footbridge leading to the
public right-of-way
this is um
graph of the interior of the site the
existing field
and this is the
location location
of the existing public right-of-way
leading off in this direction
away from Hadley Road
and then this is taken from the public
right-of-way looking back towards the
existing dwellings fronting Hadley Road
to the opposite side and then the rear
of one of the dwellings
um
fronting to the other side of Hadley
Road towards Garrett's way
and this shows the
existing uh Junction with Sawyers and
the existing uh public
path Network
which the proposed site would link into
and the existing the site is uh
here
at the end of the road there
now this is uh back down on Hadley Road
to the far south west corner of the site
might be able to make up the um
a footpath right-of-way sign here
existing dwellings to the other side of
the road
sir finally as a viewer across the site
from the south west corner
the of the site
so that concludes the presentation as
set out in the papers your officer's
recommendation is for approval thank you
chairman
thank you Alex
questions for the officer
councilor hope
yeah I've got ourselves what's happened
to the ditch in front of the field in
front of the site itself I see there's a
Footbridge what's happening to the
actual ditch has been in the field or is
it being maintained
I believe that's being maintained yes
Greenwich Village
so the access point over the ditch it
will have a drainage tube under it
there'll be no blockage to that ditch
because obviously there's been several
uh points raised about surface water
obviously if you're going to build on a
field you lose the natural drainage of
that field I appreciate the site itself
it's got a
dimensional point at the back but
resonance it seems to me impress a local
War member could give us an update on
that seemed to be concerned about the
surface water drainage on the road Etc
and I think it's essential that that
ditch is not inhibited we've had
something similar where our site's been
built in blemsford where we had natural
rain water had a flow into a field to
alleviate any flooding and since our
development's been built that is a baby
development we have a problem with
flooding so I'm very conscious of that
sort of problem
um yes acknowledge the concerns which
have been raised by um members of the
public in terms of drainage
um you know what I will say is there's
been a comprehensive
flood risk assessment and service water
drainage scheme submitted with the
application that's been assessed
um
through several revisions by lead local
flood Authority at Southern County
Council and
um
yet they are satisfied that's a
professional opinion that indeed as a
point of principle the site would not
increase the likelihood of flooding on
the site or elsewhere as is required by
the mppf and there will be conditions um
sharing additional detail is submitted
should you be minded to approve thank
you
councilor Henson you'll be next
thank you Mr chairman
um a couple of questions first of all
we're talking about 44 homes
um by my calculations 121 bedrooms how
many car parking spaces bearing in mind
that paragraph 3.6 says Hadley lies only
a short car Journey from elmset
cars are expected to be used extensively
so how many parking spaces are because
it's difficult to tell from the plans
how many parking spaces there actually
are
just a moment Council I'll go to a
report
mainly because of course we had a car
parking strategy discuss the cabinet
earlier on this week
um so we should be trying to avoid
increasing parking pressures rather than
sorry we should be reducing them rather
than increasing them
just uh just reviewed the report
um apologies the uh exact number of
parking spaces is not provided in the
reports
um however I will say it's been assessed
by SEC highways and um
a state they seem confident that it uh
meets requirements of
um advisory parking standards and uh our
pulsely tp15
so I don't have a particular number we
would have to count I'm afraid
perhaps going through anything we can
ask the agent when when he does his
presentation
yet you can by all means we might try
and get an answer this time
thank you Mr chairman
um program 3.9 10 developments not being
subject to a housing needs survey this
was an allocated site as EMS T3 but the
principle for the Cyprus 41 dwellings
not 44.
no housing need survey has been done to
comply with cs11 why is this
um well there's yes
um
I'm not sure how to answer that Mark
please
that was done as an exercise which
informed it as an allocation in the
neighborhood plan so you've identified
that it's gone up a little bit but the
the site was
um
formed as for all the sites by Elm
City's neighborhood plan
uh stage I think about two three years
ago
but hasn't been done afresh at this
point
so what you're saying is that it was
done the housing needs was done as a
party
as part of the creation of the Elmsford
neighborhood plant document
which was about two or three years ago
thank you
Council James you were next with your
hands in there oh
thanks thank you
um
on the previous application there was a
couple of things or a few things raised
by the parish council one was coming
back to the ditch they was concerned
about on the previous steps and the the
risk on the on the previous application
and also lighting and I wondered if
those matters had both been dealt with
satisfactorily
I couldn't really work out
um yes
the issue of a ditch has been addressed
by
um the surface water drainage strategy
options requiring a bit more detail to
that so make sure it's the site is
drained correctly it doesn't cause flood
risk elsewhere but yeah I mean it was
more a safety hazard I think the parish
were raised in last time and has that
been
[Music]
and the
I wasn't sure if that had been I know
you took that away last time
yes I'm not sure I'm familiar with
the depth of a ditch there's a concern
about the the depth yes
I thought you'd taken that away on the
last application last year whenever it
was reviewed the price
so it's a safety concern if someone were
to fall into the ditch this is it okay
okay
um
yes I'm not sure it's been raised as a
particular safety concerned about
apparently okay yeah yeah let's uh
yeah yeah I'm not sure quite what we do
about that but um there will be a ditch
for drainage purposes but the concern is
that that in itself presents a safety
yeah
yeah okay
okay uh the other was the lighting
because they really were not keen on
Mini lighting yes of course yes I think
there was a lighting strategy
um proposed I don't think any lighting
is currently proposed but that will be
um
Edition
the assault lighting scheme is the place
by wealth conditions so we would have
control over that great
thanks for being next
thank you Mr chairman um I've got a
couple of questions could we have slowly
eight back up please
um and I don't know whether you can uh
answer these but if not the applicant
might be able to when we get to his
state
um on the
um the slide I'm concerned as to what
sort of
um footpaths you've got there are these
tarmac footpaths or are these um
verges and edges in front of the hoses a
grass quite a lot of the area looks to
me like it's got um hedging around them
which if they have is very good because
that discourages
additional parking
because as we know on our states where
you've got either a concrete footpath
people will get their cars half on the
road and half on the footpath
and also where you've got the grass
verges they churn them up so we don't
want any of them left
can you just give some detail about that
because I can't really see there any
areas of hard standing where additional
cars could park
he um not that actually illegally but um
I'm sympathetic to the estate
so the details of the for parts quite
often the surfaces run along the front
of the properties and then they have
grass on the top and they say they can't
have
um tarmacs there because they've got to
um be able to get to them but then all
the cars park there and they get all
muddy and churn up I can take you to
many Estates where this is happening now
um I don't know whether some of the
applicants announcer rather than you but
um I would have thought the other thing
is have we got sufficient Haitian round
I can see is that hedging in front of
the play area
low level hedging or bollards or
something I don't really want Bullards
hatching but look nicer
um but if it isn't I can see cars
parking along there because this is what
happens any spaces there is they will
um where you've got three or four cars
per property they will overflow there so
we need to make sure that they can't
abuse the site
okay uh yeah that's maybe a bit more
detail than we have at the moment but
perhaps a question for the the applicant
Council appearance thank you
oh and I'd like the question to the park
and answered as well when we get to that
stage
you
thank you chair thank you Alex for that
presentation I was interested to notice
on on 12 12
um 0.1 that
um Suffolk County Council had said that
they would contribute through skills for
the secondary school sex form which is
actually in Ipswich
and um and the library Improvement
however having taught at the primary
school there I cannot see any mention or
anything to be done to the primary
school thank you
um well I uh you know this is the
recommendation we have from Suffolk
County Council
um
I'm not sure we we can do anything by
that that's you know it's all all
through cell Community infrastructure
living right yeah yeah County looks at
these applications and makes it pitch uh
based on what it feels that it needs and
obviously in this case it hasn't
expressed a need for that counselor
having taught at that school it is an
old Victorian building and if there were
any additions which there could be with
this development
um the classrooms are very cramped and I
do feel that maybe we should get back to
Suffolk County Council and bring it up
so I think it's a serious issue
thank you
thanks for the Busby did you want to
yeah just a quick thing uh slide Aid
again please Alex
look what is the body the Basin what is
that beak thing that sticks out on the
left
running track was a canal or what
um I believe that is a Swale leaving
leading to the Basin itself
it's wild whale yeah
yeah I don't know
sustained sustainable drainage okay
okay thank you Council
mclareness thank
um
Alex
um
parking is going to come up quite a lot
I think really
um on a cabinet this week they've
approved the parking strategy
were they with this application and I
raised it with them about links with
planning
together
were the planning
the parking strategy team involved in
this supplication did they review what
was proposed
um no no they didn't no not the not the
baber um
the advice we took was from uh County
highways the local Highway Authority
yeah
okay well we can yeah thank you
shut you off did you have another
account no you were okay
councilor Busby we talked about a
contribution to school transport
um for the Suffolk County Council
can we guarantee that they actually use
it for that
and who are you directing that question
to
the officer I guess
okay
um
how can we guarantee they can use I
don't think we could guarantee that they
they use it but uh the important
is the option is there for them
have they specified what they're going
to do with the with the contribution is
it going to increase the number of buses
that go out that way or frequency of it
or or what I mean it's just an arbitrary
figure I guess was it 42 000
that's not going to pay for a bus an
extra bus is it
what's it going to provide
if not if if they can't answer it then
why are we approving the contribution
well it would be towards um it would
actually be towards buses for a period
of five years
to begin with
thanks for Owen you had a question
okay on the County Council responses on
the 13th of September page 11. it says
something about
um
amendments to the proposed do not change
the position of the highways Authority
from the initial response all of the
recommended planning conditions still
apply however those reference drawings
three should be updated to three a
um about the parking and beans can you
explain that
I can't see any recommendations on
on here about the bins and the parking
okay
um
paper
it's on page 11.
um
on the County Council responses
yes I believe that is in reference to
um the uh to drawing numbers now when
the County Council initially responded
they had advisory conditions with a
drawing number
since those drawings were updated
um their comments
state that they should refer to the
updated drawing rather than the previous
drawing that they previously referred to
if that's if that's clear
um and we have
um yeah as part of the recommended
conditions we have for refuse and
recycled bins
um as part of the conditions
in the recommendation
right yeah okay okay
can I just clarify one or two points
that have been asked in the chair about
the contribution to education I'm just
having a look at the full response sorry
I hope you can hear me um from County in
in April
22.
um
they identified that there would
actually be in in response to your
questions about the primary school the
primary school level does forecast to be
Surplus places available for pupils
so that that I hope answers that in
terms of the
School transport contribution there's a
bit more detail here
um that they predicted there'll be eight
secondary age pupils forecasts to arise
from development
and the contributions sought were to
fund School transport for a minimum of
five years for secondary age pupils
at 1 205 per year therefore giving a sum
of 48 200 index linked
so that's the specific targeting of
those monies for for transporting those
children
hopefully that's helpful chair thank you
any more questions to the officer
thank you very much indeed
moving on
public speakers we have no registered
representative from the parish council
we have no registered objector we have
no registered supporter but we do have
the agent
to James Bailey you have three minutes
to address the committee thank you
good morning chair members my name is
James Bailey and I'm the planning
consultant that has been working on the
current proposals on the land east of
Hadley Road elmsed I'm joined by Joshua
Hopkins and Ben Barker from Denbury
homes and between us we should be able
to answer any of the questions that you
may have this morning
we're here today to discuss a site which
already has a series of planning
benefits an outline planning permission
for residential development was secured
in 2018 and more recently the site has
been identified in the armset
neighborhood plan for housing under EMS
T3 therefore the principle of
residential development has clearly
already been accepted and established on
the on the site
Denbury homes have now acquired the land
and have submitted a full application
for a total of 44 dwellings this
includes 15 affordable houses which has
11 affordable rent and four dwellings
for shared ownership this is in
accordance with enabled plan allocation
and this mix is supported by your own
strategic housing officers
this is a full application so members
can be confident that this scheme is
holistic and includes the required
landscaping and Open Spaces
in doing so Denbigh homes offers a
layout and a design that is far more
conducive to the character of elmset
than previous submissions
the dwellings are now set back from the
highway to provide a landscape Frontage
and this Frontage also includes a series
of Bungalows to provide a softer
transition into the site
the intention is to resurface the
existing public right-of-way on the
Northern boundary which will help to
provide a continuous link between the
existing footpath networks and this new
development this will ensure that future
residents can safely and sustainably
access the services and Facilities of
elmset whilst also ensuring existing
routes are enhanced
a large area of public open space will
also be provided via a new leap under
drainage basin utilizing good design
principles these areas of open space
will also ensure that the existing
residential dwellings to the north have
a significant buffer to the proposed
development which should help to
mitigate any potential impacts on the
residential immunity there
Denver homes are also committed to
delivering a scheme that demonstrates at
least 30 reduction in carbon emissions
to conclude the principle of residential
development has already been established
on the site through its planning history
and via the made neighborhood plan and
Denbury homes has sought to bring
forward a well-designed scheme for the
site
the proposals represent an entirely
appropriate form of development in this
sustainable location and the scheme
before you this morning has been
developed through extensive discussions
with your officers the County Council
and the parish council and there are no
objections from any of the statutory
consultees I therefore respectfully
request that members endorse their
officer's recommendation and approve the
application this morning but we are as I
say here to answer any questions that
you may have thank you very much for
your time
thank you
any questions comes to be your hand was
up very quickly
thank you
um well first of all if I can repeat
that question you heard me say earlier
um I'm concerned about Carl's parking on
verges in front of houses where we've
got
um no barrier in effect uh whether
whether it's a h or whether it's just a
grass Edge to the road can you just
comment on that please
I think it might be helpful if perhaps
the uh the case obviously were to put up
the the Landscaping slide that might
give people a bit more of an idea rather
than than the layout plan uh as I
believe there was a series of trees that
were actually proposed along there as
well
there we go
and I think it's fair to say that uh
that Denver homes again very much as
we've seen over uh over the years would
want to seek to avoid any of these
parking issues that you have correctly
identified from how should we say
politely previous schemes uh in in a
different sort of planning era it's
trying to ensure that these areas are
prohibited from people using them as you
correctly say uh for additional parking
spaces uh and as I I'm sure that this is
something that Denbury are very aware of
and would seek avoid when they're
preparing their planting schemes I don't
know if there's anything further that
perhaps Ben Barker from Denver wants to
add
could I just come in there Mr Jim can
you confirm that the foot worries are
tarmac they're not grass areas that you
walk along
in front of the houses between the the
edge of the road and the edge of
properties
is that a foot way a solid
way
yeah I can answer that one so it does it
varies between the material finish but
there is a hard surface between the
ownership of the properties and the back
of the Footwear
so what you're saying then I think it's
answered my question that I wouldn't be
able to go along there see that the
driveway is full of cars and then I pull
on to a grass burnage in front of the
house
the houses will have their own landscape
and in front of the house but the
footways will the footwears on the
carriageway will all be tarmac yeah is
there a physical obstruction stopping me
from Mountain the curb going over the
foot
and then getting onto a piece of grass
that doesn't belong to the owner
um and parking my car in front that's
where the problems come along the
Landscaping scheme as James rightly
identified seeks to address that by come
right hunting yeah thank you
talk to chairman
thanks for Hinton
chairman uh
good morning you heard my question
earlier on about parking spaces numbers
we've heard from during this week in
cabinet meeting Etc about the parking
strategy the parking is a problem
95 90 to 95 of the parking in the
district is controlled by the County
Council maybe the highways Authority but
it's on street parking and we want to
try and avoid as much on-street parking
in new developments as possible which
means having an adequate number of
spaces sometimes that might mean that we
asked for developers to put in more
spaces than the Suffolk parking standard
actually allocates because of the stuff
at parking standard allocation includes
garages which means of course that if
you feel the garage up with with junk
a polite word for antiques I suppose uh
then you're gonna park the car
on the road
and that's what we want to try and avoid
so how many parking spaces are there
because looking at the plans there are
quite a little spaces that seem to be
separated from the dwellings and we know
that people don't like using those sort
of parking spaces for the simple reason
they'd like to look at their car at
night and make sure nobody's breaking
into it
councilor Hinton has just raised are
very similar to those from councilor
beer as well people taking opportunities
to try and park uh their additional cars
which unfortunately can't control
however many uh cars uh an individual
family has but what we have got uh is
we've got 114 parking spaces and nine
additional visitor uh parking spaces as
well this has been drawn up into the uh
the plan again as you quite rightly say
with the County Council and in in
relation to their uh to their current
parking standards and I think that uh in
in relation to one of the comments that
was raised earlier obviously future
applications will be beholden to your
new adopted standards but that wasn't
the case in this one that had been put
in several months ago I think it was in
in March of this year when we actually
put the application in
I don't know uh just to come back then
so 121 bedrooms will only give 114
parking spaces so if a husband and wife
have both got cars and the child is in
the second bedroom then uh we're going
to be short aren't we
I don't expect you to answer that thank
you
Council Jameson
uh yeah firstly I'd just like to
um on the councilor's previous points I
mean you've only got to go into the road
next door garage to see exactly what
they're referring to in terms of churned
up
um
grass and cars Parks everywhere so yes
I've seen it just going to the garage
and you'll see exactly what they mean
um on other matters in terms of lighting
are you going to keep that to a minimum
because I know the village right so
there's not a lot of light in the middle
until only a couple of new
small roads and it'd be nice to keep
lightened up was low
if I if I can chair I think that's a
very good point and that has been
reiterated several times uh by the
parish when we met with them I think
it's fair to say that it would be kept
to a to a minimum uh and just looking
over it then I don't think there is any
plans for anything uh um
over and above uh what you would
normally expect from a from a newer
development but very much taking on
board I think uh the the parish council
were generally supportive of the
principals but they had made that point
along with two others uh that was very
important to them so I don't think then
there is uh anything untoward in terms
of of lighting that's being proposed
here
and currently there is there's no
lighting proposed but it is subject to
Suffolk County Council highways
department on
um the other thing you're looking for 30
reduction in CO2 how are you are you
putting in the renewable energy or and
what sort of heat are you using
yep I'll tell you definitely
um so the proposals for the site
currently include
um
50 of the dwellings to include air
source heat pumps Wastewater heat
recovery
the majority log burners as well
and they're the measures that we're
currently preparing no solar panels on
the roof
no PV panels currently proposed
and one other question if I can just
um one of the other issues raised by
um
a resident constantly and the parish
council is is the parking Hadley Road
opposite the
um access
now I know you don't have to do anything
about that but is there anything that
could be done to to alleviate the
problem or help the residents opposite
if I can check you're quite right it is
uh it's a very difficult situation here
because again this is not something that
is within Danbury homes's control it's
an existing situation and how people
Park their cars is obviously uh
something for individuals uh to deal
with
there would be the opportunity to try uh
and negate any any parking immediately
opposite but that would obviously be
counterproductive to those existing
residents there
um I think it would be very difficult uh
for uh for Denbury to to actually try
and
directly assist the uh the individual
property in this particular case
um and that would be quite hard to uh to
enforce
however we have been discussing this
with the uh with the case officer it was
raised uh
the parish council level and by
individuals as well
um and as of yet there is no there is no
definitive solution I'm afraid at the
moment I know you don't have to do I
just wondering if some kind of Goodwill
gesture or something but if you're
looking at it as
casserole and you had a question
just looking at the
career
I know us as a committee we do we do
like to see this that the the pose
dwellings would not be affordable for
young people of the village is that
something that you can put in so that
the people of the village
can have first refusal or is it
something you know you can give back to
the Village
if I can
um it's a very good question and it's
one that's prevalent in all Villages uh
that we deal with in in both mid-suffolk
and and baber how do we try and ensure
that our future Generations have the
ability the opportunity to stay in in
The Villages that they've grown up in
um and unfortunately the bit that we
can't control is the the mortgage
lenders and the the banks on there but
if there is the ability to
seek out where in a in a particular
Village
there is a register or a no need I'm
sure just just speaking with the the
guys at Denver homes there would be the
opportunity to see if we could assist in
putting them how should we say slightly
higher up the uh the order and and
obviously from from Denver's perspective
that's something that they would be
willing to work with the uh the local
community on if that's something that
comes on
foreign
yes I just come back on a couple of
points
um I think with regard to the the
entrance area
um if it was considered that yellow
lines would help then it's down to the
parish council to contact the County
councilor and ask for some to be put in
but of course it always affects the
people
um who perhaps haven't got very many
places to park but I mean that's outside
your responsibility
um
you didn't State whether you've got any
electric vehicle charging
um I'd like to think you've got one for
every dwelling but um if you can answer
that one and I don't know one of my
colleagues here
um usually at the back asks about a
defibrillator
um being put in say perhaps near the
play area or somewhere
um and I just wondered whether who that
was that's true it's not always me but
uh yeah it's it's one of it it's that
but not cost and if that was down the
Paris Council would then take a control
of it and perhaps renew it as the years
go by but anyway those two points can
you help us we're not suggesting
children in the play area are going to
need defibrillators
okay if I can't yeah I think there's two
there was two points there about uh
electric charging and defibrillators
um I think it's fair to say uh looking
uh at colleagues from Denver the
intention is to have the ability for uh
for all uh of the homes to have an
electric charging uh socket or the
ability to use that Within arms there
obviously that is then down to
individuals uh if they choose to take
that uh that's any further
um the defibrillator is an interesting
point uh and I think there is an
initiative not just in uh in our
district uh and in Suffolk but across
the country to try and ensure that there
is more and more of these available and
we are seeing this on many many of our
applications
so much so that we have spoken about
this before and we've been advised by uh
by Denbury that one of the things that
they look at during their construction
of their properties uh is that on the
site they have a defibrillator available
so that should anything happen to any of
their construction workers there there
is something on site so there's a health
and safety element and I think it's fair
to say uh obviously looking over at the
guys from Denver if they're happy that
that could be gifted over to the
community wherever perhaps the community
would want to see it because it's not
necessarily going to be on this
development it might be better located
somewhere else that is definitely
something that we would consider and be
able to to gift over if that is of help
well Mr chairman I think on that we
should accept that and I think that's
very very good thank you
return returning to councilor Owens
point about local need for
affordable housing I think there's a way
to approach this in terms of policy and
there's a and as part of the conditions
because there this is a full application
so it's possible for us to require I
think as a condition that a proportion
of the affordable housing be received
priority for local
connections and is it possible for us to
include that I'm asking a mixture of
officers and the applicant if they would
be willing to acknowledge they I don't
know the percentage is often used it's
about a third sometimes it depends
obviously what the local need might be
but if we could establish as a principle
and a condition that the proportion
should be allocated for people with a
local connection would that be
acceptable to the applicant and is that
acceptable in policy terms let me find a
Gateway for Home Choice obviously make
the decision
to be Central in policy terms before we
it's difficult in policy terms to do
that the way the whole thing has been
considered is on a district-wide basis
so the response from strategic housing
was based on that and the type in tenure
is based on that as well it didn't have
any dispensation for a local connection
they do look at that when the applicants
come along but I don't think it's
anything we can very easily write into
the 106 or to any condition
unfortunately
I've been advised recently by colleagues
in strategic housing that we've had a
bit of a problem even when we have these
Provisions that if a registered provider
Housing Association is looking for grant
funding homes England don't like strict
local government uh local connection
provisions
wide and that has caused practical
issues I'm afraid sorry to say that but
I can see why that would be the case Ian
but I mean we have been told in previous
applications that the only time we can
ask for such Provisions is at this level
of either a full application or in
outline permission and and so if this is
the only time we can ask
this is the only term this is the time I
think we have to ask frankly it's it's
that there are ways in which we can hook
in um truly local needs such as red
schemes for example this this uh it's a
standard planning application with a
standard affordable provision um
all I can do is I can I can note on the
decision notice that members would like
us to have discussion with strategic
housing about whether it's possible to
prioritize uh local needs but my feeling
is in policy terms it might be difficult
to achieve that okay so if not secured
encouraged
okay well I think on the basis of
something is better than nothing
encouraged is better than uh
thank you
I have a question are you happy that um
you've spread out the affordable homes
they seem to be in two little enclaves
and I personally when I first saw the
parents thought they would be better off
in at least four but but um
I don't know whether that whether that's
practical to do or whether
um
is there any other way of coming
overcoming the problem I just thought
that they were a little bit next to each
other
directly to yourself a good point
um at the end of the day the
the council is very insistent on trying
to Pepper Pot uh where we can affordable
housing throughout any form of
development we've got a certain size
here but I I think when I made a note it
might be helpful if the case officer
could put slides eight uh back up first
of all for us because that indicates uh
well that one I'll do first of all it
doesn't matter there we go so there is a
portion of the affordable further to the
South and they have an Outlook over the
fields Beyond
so that is one smaller cluster of the
affordables and then if you go and then
actually on that same plan there is a
series uh of uh five uh affordable
properties uh in one area as well and
then again on slide eight there are the
affordables that made up uh that make up
the 15 and they Overlook the uh the leap
so one of the things that we have done
is to try to give the the properties
there a particular view as well again we
know that there is a it isn't a
definitive policy but there is a
requirement that we don't have uh
clusters of more than 15 we have got 15
here but we've tried to space them out
as best that we can and that was the
sort of rationale of where we've come to
and we'd worked that through with the
Strategic housing officer and with your
uh your offices as well to get to this
point on the layout
you are happy with you
yes yes we are we think that there is a
a good location for them uh and how they
are laid out
also I would say the registered
providers though don't split up too much
either in terms of manage for a
management perspective
I can understand that comment doesn't
mean to say I agree with you
thank you
any more questions
if not thank you very much indeed
Chad before you move on can I just
that's a number crunching on the parking
carry on uh whilst uh people were
talking um I think we've got this right
so I
I have it here that if you look at the
numbers of bedrooms and just to remind
them there's two bedroom houses would
require two spaces three bedroom houses
also two spaces four bedroom three
spaces it's silent on five beds but
therefore take it to be three spaces but
even if it's four spaces because the
extra bedroom
um you would need 98 spaces for that so
obviously it covers that if you then
look at the visitor parking that's it um
after the quarter of the number of
dwellings that's 11 and a quarter so
that gives us grand total if you if you
have four spaces for five beds we have a
grand total of
109.25 spaces that's what the standards
say
so it's a little bit over there
thank you Mark
no more questions let's move into debate
thanks
councilor James and you're the ward
member you can I invite you you don't
have to if you don't wish to open no
thanks um yeah what I want to say at
this point is um
was I mean the plan and that line of
commission was agreed on this site
four or five years ago so it's been
dragging on and on this development is a
much I think and I think the parish
Council certainly agree is a much nicer
development than the previous one and
they seem to have
agreed to cover at least most of the
points that were raised against the
previous development even when it came
to us last year or earlier this year
um yes it is three more properties than
were agreed but um it looks nicer and um
the um however I
am a bit disappointed that they're not
putting any renewable
um especially in the particular climate
at the moment it would have been nice
for at least some effort to put in some
solar panels
and um help and it's help with the
residents Heating
bills in the future
um but as it's then I wait to see what
other other members say but um yeah at
the moment I'm yeah it's
that aside it's it's a nicer development
I think than previously agreed and as
one's already been agreed
um we'd only fall back on that I believe
so
apparently I'll help you with the next
yeah thank you I I still have picking up
on issues from the parish council about
the parking and Hadley Road and I
appreciate we've already touched on that
it isn't necessarily the developers
responsibility to resolve that
but what they are going to do from what
I can see is create a problem that
wasn't there before it would appear to
me that we're the entrance to this
particular site is is probably in front
of the only properties along that road
that don't actually have parking in
front of their houses or in their
property on their property so we're
going to create a problem for probably
from what I can see three at least three
properties that currently use the road
now again it's not necessarily your
problem you're building your site but we
represent our residents and our
residents are going to be impacted by
this development so I do have concerns
that the entrance to the site is in a
location that's going to create a
problem for those residents in Hadley
Road and I can't really see sitting here
a way around that obviously because the
design of the site is designing the site
but I think our planners really need to
pick up on that and
you know we don't want to create
problems for our residents and this to
me is going to create parking issues in
Hadley Road that aren't going to be easy
for those residents to overcome there is
no real place to park other than in the
road and I think their concerns really
rely on the The Sweep of the entrance
into the site which is going to directly
impact those people
and I still have a concern about the
ditch we've mentioned the depth of the
ditch from a safety point of view but
we've seen developments like this before
you build on a field it changes the
whole landscape of natural drainage and
you're creating problems again you've
done your best to alleviate your site
but the knock-on effect is
that the natural drainage is is
interrupted and is actually impacted by
a development like this so I don't know
the answers but realistically going
forward we need to think of our resonant
outside of the site and not necessarily
just within the site
thank you councilor beer
um thank you Mr chairman we're just
carrying on from that point my fellow
councilor
um I I sometimes wonder uh whether
um
A Way Forward on some of these and the
officers could perhaps look at this in
the future in great Corner we had a
situation where the developer actually
allowed a strip of land to be
handed over to 23 residents who had they
gave them a parking space each but that
couldn't be allocated to per house
although the 23 houses did use it to
park their cars because that was the
only place in front of their houses they
moved the road further over gave them
this bit of around in front created the
parking spaces but even I can go and
park there the locals they can't give it
to the locals apparently because of some
do highways but it did work
whether they're I think it's too late
now in the scheme to to have a little
area uh just inside the site where they
could create three or four car parking
spaces just for those residents but as I
say I don't think you can earmark it
just for those
um particular properties that are
affected
but moving on from that
um I I think this particular company's
done very well it's uh come back with a
much better plan
um yes they've done quite a lot on it
and they've certainly
um answered all my queries regarding the
um
um unsatiable Park and I'll call it
um we've got quite a few parking spaces
there yes there's never enough I think
for three bedroom houses we should have
three parking spaces but that's not in
your gift as perhaps in ours or counties
um but that aside the electric charging
points I think is very good we've got
the defibrillator which will eventually
be gifted to the parish council
um and I I feel Mr chairman that they've
done quite a lot here so I'm prepared to
move the officer's recommendation I
would just say on the question of um
solar panels which I I understand where
you come from and I've had them put on
my house but the cost is between 10 and
15 1000
and I know you'd get a cheaper if you're
buying it for 44 homes but that means
the house price goes up by another 10
000 pounds and people are struggling now
so yes we ought to encourage people to
put them on but I don't think we should
create a higher bill for people to get
on the housing ladder to start with so I
moved the officer's recommendations to
Chairman thank you
do we have a second
floor
say anything
but no I think beyond the fact that the
application seems to do what it reports
to do it what it said on the tin I think
I mostly impressed the fact that it's
been carried out in conjunction with the
parish council that is the collaborative
process and that it's improved the
application through each of the stages
to arrive at something that Elms it is
is I wouldn't say perfectly happy about
but comfortable with if that's a fair
point
I'm asking the award member if they were
to concur with that view because yeah I
mean I think the whole point is that we
have a neighborhood plan here this
conforms to the neighborhood plan and
that's what's the point of having the
neighborhood plans if we don't try to
conform
yeah if we're doing proposing secondly
just to remind that there's going to be
an extra condition about defibrillator
okay yeah we're going to carry on the
debate for us
kind of surprised but you wish to yeah I
know that you can find a slide that
shows the road I've got a question about
where the 30 model now starts
thank you
anybody know where the 13 water now
starts on on that road
so that is well within the 30 mile an
hour limit okay that's
cool any other comments from anyone
comes to hold yeah picking up on what I
said earlier Chad um I'm not sure I'm
not disrespectful to color fellow
members but
I have to go and Google Earth
to see the visualize the entrance
I don't know how many other people here
members actually know what I'm talking
about when I express My Views about the
entrance but it might be useful going
forward to actually use
Google Earth from an officer
presentation to show us in real terms
what we're looking at other than a
drawing
Because unless you've got real local
knowledge which councilor Jameson has
just looking at a diagram you have no
concept of of the
probably three properties
we take that away councilor holds a fair
point thank you
thank you genuine
Joe to win thank you I believe there's
been a site visit where these were
pointed out these entrances I believe
but um not everybody in this room at the
moment made the same visit
any more comments cancer hint sorry
thank you very much
um just just a quick one uh
his majesty the Queen the title of the
king
man uh his majesty the king is as long
advocated the environmental measures and
has recently spoken just before
tragic loss of his mother about the need
to put in
Swift boxes and Swift bricks and
Hedgehog
corridors and these sorts of things can
we ask the developer to consider uh
active measures to improve on the
environment bearing in mind that this is
on the outskirts of a village and
therefore he's the first part of
development that Wildlife comes across
as it's coming up from the south and so
there is likelihood likely to be a
considerable impact uh
an improvement
possible for for wildlife on from this
this development
thank you
would you like to come I'm quite happy
for you to make a comment we're allowed
to to come back in apologies intruding
on on the device absolutely uh this this
should be given across most developments
uh that come forward across your
committees now and I can confirm uh
absolutely Denbury homes are all over
this uh and I believe I believe that
it's actually already included uh within
our application it's something that they
take very seriously and will be doing on
their developments going forward
just just for clarification the fourth
from bottom bullet point condition does
cover this already
but you've made some explicit comments
about Swift
um bricks so we'll make sure they're
included
script boxes boxes bricks
it's usually on the species specific
sorry
well did you say specifically
condition
the Swift boxes
uh yeah sure I'll ensure that um I take
a note that Swift boxes should be
included it's already covered by the
fourth and button condition anyway
are you happy with that
I I put my trust more in mother nature
but I'm quite happy to go along with
that I don't think it's necessary but uh
anyway I'll go along with it
I'm happy with that and I haven't got
the same faith in Mother Nature that her
Catholic beer has I had a I had a house
Martin's Nest collapse and leaves of our
house
um spilling the chicks
um a swift brick wouldn't have done that
thank you
I'm trying to suppose we used to come in
so if I can refer back to the the
applicant um Denbury homes it's it's a
new name to me to me it's wonder if
there's any developments in the area
that you have done that
we might know
so demry homes has actually uh an
existing company called Hopkins and more
so we owned a company called Hopkins
homes and Denver homes formed a part of
that effective
ly no no so Hopkins homes was
established
um
by the same person who owns Hopkins or
more and effectively we sold Hopkins
homes in January but retained Hopkins
and more and rebranded that Danbury
homes right
thank you macaroni cheese but thank you
any more
coming
back to the halt
she turned it off
public Open Space Management plan it's
to be agreed I'll take it that we it is
part of the conditions
um again we've had several sites within
the district that have the public open
space I'm going to developer walks away
within a year it looks awful and we seem
to have problems managing it or getting
people to return to manage it so I just
want to make sure that we do have
something in place that is actually
deliverable so that this scheme isn't
blighted by a an area of land that's not
maintained and looks horrible
that that's the idea part of the
agreement or the plan is it's is its
life basically so that should be colored
by that but do we have the power to
enforce it
ultimately yes
can we
if we can't enforce it we shouldn't put
it as a condition so it's enforcement
and and the pushes and that that they um
have to
um make sure that they it's a value five
years so if they died which we had a
situation in corner after two or three
years some trees put in and the
companies came back and replaced them
but it is down to the locals and the
parish council to bring this to the
attention of the management committee or
whatever you call them because
um
with all the Goodwill in the world I was
expecting maybe just a council to sort
these trees out and it wasn't until I
got in touch with the chief planning
officer
they then went after the developers and
they of management and they then came
back and did the the replanting so it is
something that's there but I think there
has to be a little bit of input by local
members the parish council and locals
thank you indeed share the resource
isn't there to proactively check
everything's okay so we do blind people
to let
on one of my developments recent very
recently and it was planning enforcement
actually the that checked on it and it
was a five-year limit and which the
developers have actually done it was
very successful okay
thank you thank you cancer changing
uh just coming back to the the solar
panels I mentioned
um there's three solar Farms on the
outskirts of elm State uh
are in in planning with us in
mid-suffolk at the moment and just want
to say it is so frustrating for
residents to see land being given over
to solar farms and new developments
going in with no solar panels on the
roof that could have them
time and time again people are asking
you know why are we taking over land and
blightly potentially blight in the land
as they say and but not putting them on
new houses
thank you I've just in the bottom of
page 26 members you've got a catch-all
condition about sustaining
host any decisions by you today so we
can hook in things like that I can't
promise we'll do lots of solar panels
but there's evidence sustainability
measures condition there
thank you Mr chairman
um on the coastal solar panels and the
cost of them uh my son rents his roof
out
he gets the free electricity from solar
panels and the person who owns the
panels gets the fit payment so there is
a there are schemes available which
means there's no capital outlay for the
uh for the homeowner
thank you I
I think you better put potential beer in
contact with us
all right okay thank you thank you are
there any more comments
before we go so the panel shopping
no in that case I'll ask Claire to
conduct the vote
to clarify the extra conditions
defibrillators um chair yeah
um I think because planes obviously I've
heard the developers said they'll give
it to the community but that stops gonna
you phrase shall provide on site unless
otherwise agreed by a separate discharge
of condition so that makes it nice and
planningy and we can do that and but the
informatives will include a reference to
Swift boxes and um
a plea for local needs help if possible
secondary and for those of you happy
with those
no
thank you then Claire to carry on the
vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in Europe
would you like me to take your vote
verbally account responsible for thank
you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous
the application dc2103561
has been withdrawn by the applicant so
we're not doing that today the only
other visit is there was a site visit
towardsley Grange taking place next
Wednesday the next meeting of this
committee will be on the 19th of October
the it says here in the think room
think
I think
Elizabeth fig what used to be called the
Elizabeth
the meeting I will now formerly closed
the meeting thank you